[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes I'm John Connolly Spectators
news editor and your host this week
coming up on the show
the American midterms didn't go as well
for the Republicans as they'd hoped what
happened I'll speak to Freddie gray and
Lionel Shriver
is Adam at miliband really in charge of
Labor and what does Gavin Williamson's
resignation say about Westminster I'll
speak to James Forsyth and Isabelle
Hardman
I mean Matthew's writes in this week's
magazine about the evolution of nuclear
weapons would Russia using them be as
suicidal as it once was would he'll join
the show
companions in Scotland are trying to
cancel the philosopher David Hume what's
going on I'll speak to Stuart waiton and
with Christmas approaching we'll discuss
the books of the year with Sam Leith
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator TV then do subscribe to our
YouTube channel just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon so you never miss an
episode
first up ahead of the American midterms
this week there was talk of a republican
Red Wave sweeping across the country as
the results come in though it appears
that Democrats haven't done as quite as
badly as was thought Freddie gray our
Deputy editor writes the cover piece for
this week's magazine saying the only
real winner was paranoia to explain he
joins me now alongside spectator
columnist and author Lionel Shriver
now Freddie needs to start us off then
before the midterms this week there was
a big talk of a sort of Red Wave that's
going to sweep across the country where
the Republicans doing particularly well
um it turns out that didn't happen uh
what's what's going on here
we never believe uh Republican insiders
when they tell you with great confidence
there's going to be a red wave I mean I
think what happened is that over the
summer the Democrats thought that
because of the overturning of Roe v Wade
and because of certain things Biden had
done that they had a bit of momentum and
that actually there was going to be a
Blue Wave to counter the Red Wave they
exaggerated that
the Republicans seized on that and sort
of created a counter narrative in the
certainly in the media
um that they uh that they were going to
have the red wave and that the Democrats
got it all wrong they were focusing on
abortion too much
um and actually all people cared about
was the economy I think that was right
but it wasn't enough
to uh to to create a red wave and in
fact it ended up being a fairly similar
result in many ways to to what's
happened in the last two four years I
mean Lionel Freddie mentioned their sort
of Roe v Wade how much of a factor do
you think that was as the kind of you
know supporting the Democrats this time
as a line that could push
I think it clearly got up the vote
especially among younger women for
self-interested reasons
um
you know that that's the kind of
determination that we'll wait for poll
analyzes so I would have no reason to
to have any access to that but it was
clearly a motivating factor
I don't know whether it was
determinative in a lot of races the the
little data we've got suggests that it
was actually more significant than I
think CNN had an exit poll that showed
it was the economy was 42 and abortion
was something like 38 36 so it was more
significant than a lot of Republicans
were giving a credit for but this was
one of those weird issues where the
Republicans problem was winning
they got what at least a considerable
proportion of them wanted with the
Supreme Court decision but it wasn't
something that the Republican Party
directly did but they got blamed for it
because it was a trumpian supreme court
so
um at the same time though I would add
that the the Republican Governors who
had signed uh anti-abortion measures all
won quite convincingly so okay that's an
interesting Dynamic that isn't being
talked about a lot and in terms of the
winners and losers from this midterms
there's a little talk that sort of
candidates that Trump has endorsed in
particular haven't done particularly
well like as it Mehmet Oz in
Pennsylvania do you think this is sort
of Lionel sort of kind of thrown Donald
Trump off now and sort of diminished his
his sort of hold of the Republican party
a little bit or do you think that's sort
of wishful thinking
well I know that's the way it's this
midterm is so far being interpreted
um it is a it is the narrative as we say
but
I'm not entirely sure it's true but I
want it to be true and the thing about
the narrative is that
when you take a story and just run with
it you can make it true okay so I'm not
going to differ with this one I like it
I like the idea that uh Trump has been
knocked off his game that he's losing
his popularity that the people that he
backed well a lot of them did secretly
get through
um but we're not going to pay attention
to that we're only going to focus on the
people he he endorsed and they lost so
his influence is waning and then we look
to Florida of course and Ron DeSantis of
who has won my heart personally
um and is now you know he's the future
uh he's you know we should be looking to
DeSantis for 24. uh Trump is is an
increasingly spent Force I think that's
terrific now is it true
not so sure well it's about you Freddie
do you buy into that narrative well I'm
a sort of very very boring knee-jerk
contrarian and I'm a sort of narrative
pervert actually so I think that it
isn't really true and I still think that
Trump is very hard to beat in the
Republican nomination and I think
everybody wants certainly everybody you
know you talk to in Britain uh a lot of
people in journalism uh and a lot of
Americans do you know but but the
problem is you know the Trump movement
is very very powerful
and there are a lot of people who will
always vote for Trump even against Ronda
santis and I think it will get very
nasty against Rhonda centers and I do
think it's quite funny listening to I'm
not talking about Lionel here but I I've
spoken to very sort of Lefty friends of
mine last couple days who think that
Rhonda Santos is great and I said you
realize he's like he's more right-wing
than Donald Trump and and he means it
you know he's not going to just give up
on it because he doesn't care
um he's a very very serious conservative
very devout Catholic very pro-life very
anti-immigration
uh and so what I think will be if he
does win if the census doesn't what will
be very funny is watching Once Trump's
out the way he will become Trump but
sort of evil and cleverer I mean Lana
you said he's had a bit of soft spot for
DeSantis I mean why do you think he's
done so well in Florida
well because
he is taking possessions that for
Floridians
share I mean it's it's simple you know
they're not big on immigration and
ironically it has very large Hispanic
population but they don't want more
immigrants even Hispanic immigrants
they're already there
you know close the door
um they really like his legislating on
teaching radical gender ideology to
six-year-olds they don't want their kid
to be asked before they can spell
whether or not they're a girl or a boy
or something in between
and the critical race Theory stuff or
whatever you want to call it because
Democrats claim there's no such thing
it's not popular either it's it's
divisive
it's dependent on making white people
feel guilty and ashamed and
you know it's it's ugly it's it's in
it's it's an ugly and uh and vicious
ideology which isn't very popular with
just about anything I was gonna say do
you think that can cut through to sort
of the rest of the country as well it's
not just a Florida these are larger
issues that would appeal to the rest of
the country and honestly
DeSantis also made himself very popular
through the coronavirus epidemic and
that pandemic excuse me
um
because
instead of just knee jerk
Following the Leader
um he consulted a lot of of scientists
of of a broad range of perspectives and
came to the conclusion that this kind of
heavy-handed uh lockdown approach
didn't work and and had all kinds of
downsides oh surprise he's right
um so you know he endeared himself to
the state but he also endeared himself
to the larger country because even
though Florida has a high degree of
elderly people
um it didn't have worse mortality stats
than anybody else so it you know Florida
was one of those States like South
Dakota that helped to demonstrate to
everyone that these Draconian policies
uh have all kinds of downsides and don't
even do what it says on the team
that's a quite a good joke on social
media that said that the reason there
wasn't Red Wave is because every
Republican has moved to Florida
which I think is actually maybe a little
bit yeah
but yeah I think I think that covert as
Malone says the covert thing is was is
hugely significant in the census appeal
and his success it doesn't necessarily
mean that he's a a winner Nationwide
um but he's extremely popular and
impressive
on the um abortion front I mean it's
true he's he's wildly pro-life and I'm
pro-choice so I don't see eye-to-eye
with him at all but were he to become
president that has become a an issue for
the state so his position as uh in the
Federal Executive wouldn't have any
effect on National policy it's true that
the Democrats have
made a gesture toward trying to get
Federal legislation through which they
couched in such extreme terms that it
didn't have a chance so that's why I
characterized it as a gesture they
didn't really want to get that through
did they because it was so useful for
them
yeah they did it on purpose so after
this now where does this kind of leave
the damage oh where does it leave Biden
I mean he's in a presumably a strong
position to run now if he wants to do so
I think so I have a sneaky theory that
actually uh the Democrats are hoping
that he'll think I'm not a disaster I
can go now but I don't think that's
probably real why would you think that
the Democrats are hoping he's going to
well I mean because two-thirds of the
country doesn't want him to run he isn't
he isn't uh popular he isn't like he is
quite divisive I think he's a clever
politician than people like me tend to
give him credit for I think and I you
know I think you have I have to check my
prejudices yeah on that because I think
you know
for instance the coal thing last week
everybody thought it was really dumb of
him to uh say that he was gonna what
take out coal and it does seem to be
dumb but actually uh what happens is
Mansion who is actually pretty good pals
with and I think they agree all this
stuff beforehand uh Mansion says
absolutely outrageous statements and so
mentioned does well in West Virginia
with the coal mining Community there and
then young voters say oh Barnes willing
to take this Flack he's actually he is
one of us so he he's he's understood the
the kind of the radical left if you like
uh of America is quite a potent
electoral force and he's quite good at
tapping into it while seeming like this
benevolent Grandpop do you think he'll
run Lionel
I think the pressure on him to step down
is going to be enormous
and
it's possible that he's just bloody
minded enough
to persevere but that doesn't mean that
he's going to run unopposed you know
traditionally
when you've got an incumbent up for a
second term everyone steps aside and
it's just
there you go
um but but this time I don't think that
I think he would get some serious
Challengers and we should mention as
well you're writing this week's magazine
a fantastic skewing of Kamala Harris I
presume you'll be hoping will not take
over
well my uh
my nightmare uh scenario is Trump does
secure the Republican nomination
and runs against Kamala Harris
and I don't approve of not voting as a
form of voting but I do not that puts me
in a state of perfect paralysis
you know I'd run weeping to a closet
there's this sort of you know the dark
Brandon me yeah this idea that Biden
pretends to be senile and all that but
he's actually this genius
he's playing 4D chess all the time it's
a sort of something applied to Biden but
the theory with that is that he Cameron
Harris was a genius appointment because
it was the vice president that would
never ever threaten him and nobody quite
realized how bad she would be but she
has been that bad I mean like light up
for viewers who aren't as familiar with
kamala's record I mean why why do you
think she's so bad
well not to put too fine a point on it
she's a blithering idiot and she and I
do mean blithering so you can see clip
after clip on the web of her
not just being inarticulate uh in
redundant you know using the same
expression over and over and over again
while she just Paws in place
um but uh she's clearly not prepared
so not only is she very
bad on her feet but you know when you
know that at three o'clock you're
supposed to show up and give a 15-minute
presentation might maybe you would give
it a moment's thought you know you're
going to be on camera you're
representing your Administration and she
hasn't and it's obvious
that she has no idea what she's and she
she's somebody who expresses too much
confidence in herself for you for for no
reason you know if Kamala has watched
her own clip she knows she has to come
up with you know a whole Sheaf of very
specific notes and just read from them
you know because she she should not be
able to trust herself she can't
extemporize but instead she just thinks
oh I can wing it this is some you know
lower order uh comment on Transportation
policy I I'll think of something and
then of course she doesn't she doesn't
and
who wants a president like that it's
like you know you show up talking to the
Kim Jong-un or something and you you you
you just say uh oh uh or uh we've always
been allies with North Korea I mean she
actually said that right in a demon
authorized Zone she couldn't remember
the difference between North and South
Korea to me that's just game over fair
enough she was kept well hidden too in
the midterms right yeah the Democrats
realized quite how devastating she is
for them and finally Freddie to finish
this off
um it looks as we're recording that the
kind of Republicans going to take the
house the Senate's kind of still up for
grabs what does that kind of mean for
Biden for the for the rest of his term
now is it kind of made life a lot more
difficult for him well I think first of
all let's say that the isn't it absurd
that we're now two days until after the
the election and we don't know a lot of
the results and in the the world's most
advanced sophisticated democracy it is
pretty crazy that I think and there's so
much hanging on it you know Global
markets are all just sort of wavering
around what's going to happen in the
Senate and I just find that
extraordinary but as for what it means
for Biden if if what happens looks like
happens probably they will just there
will be 50 50 in the Senate again
because they'll probably win Georgia
again I think and then they'll have this
narrow majority in sorry the Republicans
will have the narrow majority in the
house
it might Scupper some of the more
ambitious Republican plans to pursue him
to indict him over or to try and impeach
him over Hunter Biden and the laptop and
things like that which is a shame
because I'd like that story a lot and I
was hoping that that would become a a
sort of a Biden impeachment story would
dominate next year but I think it's
going to be difficult for the
Republicans so they they are now having
to deal with a Maga Wing the way that
Biden has to deal with his uh Ultra
Progressive Wing brilliant thank you
Freddie and thank you Lionel
Isabelle Hardman writes in this week's
magazine that Ed miliband is the power
behind kirst armor the former labor
leader she says is the one coming up
with the party's policy positions to
explain to give us an update on the
week's politics Isabelle joins me now
alongside James Forsyth
as well you write in the magazine this
week about how Ed Millard Gand became
the sort of power behind the throne in
labor can you um tell us a bit about
that please
yeah so it's as much a piece
of PK stormers weakness I suppose as it
is about how influential Edge miliband
is it's something that has been
frustrating more and more labor front
benches over the past few months just
how easily Ed miliband manages to get
his policy ideas uh implemented into
being official party policy and how much
of a hearing he gets not just from kirst
armor but also Rachel Reeves
um who obviously had you know worked
with a long time ago when he was party
leader himself and it's a really
interesting question which is
the electorate obviously quite
resoundingly rejected Ed miliband in
2015. and yet he's still really managing
to influence a lot of labor party policy
to the extent that you might say that
starmerism is really a sort of
re-garnished milibandism so if you look
at the policies that were announced at
Party Conference in uh earlier in the
Autumn
um the state-backed energy
um company being one of them spending
quite as much money as Rachel Reeves
announced on climate change this party
slogan for that conference which was
fair A Greener future and that did lead
to an internal row about whether to
Rebrand Labor's red rose to a green one
which
um the greatest of all complaints
against would be that you can't have
green roses obviously
um but he is just he's very good at
getting his ideas across and that's not
a you know it's not a sort of sinister
thing uh it shows that he works hard
he's someone that people like to have
around
but it does suggest that K stalma
himself
lacks vision and ideas of his own
there's a lot joke that some front
Ventures like to have which is kissed
armor is the sort of the hole in the
donut when it comes to labor party
policy as opposed to the jam and I think
we're seeing that Ed miliband is is
providing the jam now if you talk to
um if you talk to people in the front
bench they'll also say well this is
partly as a result of admin abandon Lucy
Powell talking themselves up and saying
that you know they're much more
influential than they are but uh but
it's actually difficult to see uh the
the influence of others in quite the
same way so I think it's you know so
it's an important issue to cover and
something that is increasingly aerating
labor front benches and James obviously
voters have rejected milibandism once
um is there a danger here for labor that
they sort of follow this past down do
you think or do you think they can sort
of get away with it a bit now because
the Tory party had been in such disarray
so I think one of the most fascinating
things in Israel's art school is her
point about how Edmund abandoned and and
those close to him feel confindicated by
events they look at the fact that you
know the state is now stepping in to pay
People's Energy bills the kind of
government initiatives that you saw
during covid and they feel that the
world has kind of adjusted to them you
know and I think that what I think is
interesting is people politically are
always dangerous when they feel they
were just ahead of their time and that
makes them much more inclined to kind of
push their ideas
I think labor the big question to my own
for labor is what do they do when this
Autumn statement comes along uh next
week which is that there are two options
there is the 97 option and the 92
options the 97 option is to accept
essentially accept the Tory envelope you
know you might tweak it a bit at the
margin so you're going to tax non-doms
more and use that to spend that money on
more nurses for the NHS or something
like that but but the fundamentals of
tax and spend you are accepting
um which is what label did in 97 and it
and it shuts down uh the Tory ability to
say ah labor are going to borrow more
and you don't know how the markets will
react to that the other option the
Bolder option is the 1992 option when
labor had their own shallow budget and
they didn't accept the government
Baseline and I think we will learn a lot
from Kia storm about which path he
chooses to go down following that Autumn
statement as well did you think there
was a bit of a move away from it in a
sense with starmer saying sort of
criticizing the extinction Rebellion
protesters this week or do you think
he's is he trying to shake off the the
shackles of milibandism do you think
I'm not sure to refer to Ed miliband
that he was he's ever really been a sort
of
fiction Rebellion kind of politician
um I mean actually if you think back to
the 2015 election this is obviously you
know not about eco
uh Warriors but about trade unions a
clip that went viral of him was him just
saying over and over again like a robot
uh these strikes are wrong about uh
about some industrial action that a
trade Union uh was taking so he's he's
probably unfair to say that he he would
um if given the chance be gluing himself
to anything uh apart from obviously the
leader's office but uh I think case
Thomas's uh Extinction Rebellion as
being I guess an easy win in the sense
that lots of people within the climate
movement
um and just stop oil sorry and insulate
Britain uh being the two sort of more
militant
um groups than Extinction Rebellion but
I think he sees them as being an easy
win
um because even within the climate
movement there's a lot of people who
find their tactics really abhorrent and
you know increasingly so with the
vandalization of of
um paintings and uh the uh the protests
that happened this week in Essex it's
it's actually one of those things that
is it's quite easy to criticize that and
so why not go for it um and why not
confound the expectations of people
who've caricatured you there's much
harder positions that clear storm is
going to have to take than people gluing
themselves to Motorway gantries I think
I think one of those is going to be this
question of of public sector strikes
because I think it is a very difficult
question which is you look at the fact
the Royal College of Nursing have voted
for industrial action now I should say
that that won't affect emergency care
but it's obviously going to make these
NHS waiting lists that we talk about so
much on this program worse but but the
case is not straightforward you know
obviously the nurses are asking for a
large pay rise above inflation but what
they are likely to be offered is
substantially below inflation and you
know how defensible is it that they that
they should be asked to take a real-time
pay card but obviously if you want them
to their wages to keep up with inflation
you know that is going to require
considerably more public spending and so
I think one of the things that is I mean
look these strikes
let's not miss the key point it's
obviously going to be very difficult for
the government but I mean there is also
a tricky question for labor in how they
respond to them because
if you are telling the NHS to you know
meet nurses whole EG give them a pay
rise it is commensurate of inflation
that is a big chunk out of our NHS
budget and you know where you know is
that going to be Cuts elsewhere in the
budget or are you going to raise more
money from taxation to pay for it and
Isabel we've also seen the toys have
their own sort of fair share of woes
this week with the departure of Gavin
Williamson
um do you think that the whole
Williamson Saga has been handled well by
number 10.
no I don't think so not least because he
really went on his own terms in that he
wasn't pushed out he had a nice letter
of acceptance of his resignation from
Rishi sunak in which the Prime Minister
thanked him for his support and loyalty
it's almost as if when Michelle's
talking about the allegations against
Gavin Williamson which we should say he
vigorously denies uh he always wants to
separate out what he calls these serious
allegations uh from the man they're
being made against continues to praise
Gavin Williamson and says he has full
confidence in him but these are serious
allegations completely coincidentally
almost and so that has made where she's
seen that look quite weak because it
suggests that Gavin Williamson still has
for whatever reason quite a bit of power
over him um and that he's not the person
who is calling the shots in terms of
personnel uh not helped obviously by the
Sue Ella bravaman situation somewhere
it's pretty clear that she was
reappointed home secretary in order to
secure
um as part of a promise to secure her
support in the very short leadership
contest that led to Rishi Cena becoming
Tory leader and prime minister and so
it's you know politically it's not been
handled well but in a wider context as
well there seems to be no discussion of
the thing that James and I have been
banging on about phrases which is that
the whips office and you know this is
about Gavin Williamson not the whips
office but some of the allegations
um concern his behavior as a whip
um you know the whips offices is just
not fit for purpose anymore whether it's
in the conservative party or indeed
other parties the labor party it's it's
wrong for instance to have MPS who need
financial support because of you know a
crisis a gambling addiction whatever to
be getting that from the party whips who
may then the following week phone them
up and say just checking you're with us
on this controversial vote there's just
such a clear conflict of interest there
and that yet that was something that you
know emerged this week one of the
allegations against Williamson came from
former deputy chief with Ann Milton that
when some financial support was being
provided he said to Anne Milton make
sure they know that I own them now and
she was clear she didn't think that was
a joke so you know even when you don't
have
um performatively Machiavellian
characters in The whips office you have
that conflict between the Pastoral and
the political which everyone knows
exists and yeah you know nothing gets
done about it and so on comes the next
Scandal whenever it is I mean James do
you get the sense that Tory party is
becoming harder to govern as well I mean
it seems like we're just sort of rolling
through scandal after Scandal and
there's also a lot of like back bench
there's a lot of it's coming from Toy
back benches often as well so I mean Jay
Merrick uh has an astonishing statistic
that on average someone has resigned
once every four days this year which
gives you a flavor of the kind of time
it has been in in Westminster
I think there is a big question as to
whether this resonates which is
obviously initially what set the ball
rolling I don't even was
um messages he'd exchanged with the
former Chief Whip and the fact that the
former party chairman had you know was
saying that there was that there was
this this that this had been referred
these messages have been referred to
cchq so I mean the question is was this
a particular animals because of kind of
Gavin Williamson and how he behaved or
does it foretell like on a broader fact
that jewelry party is still fighting
each other
um and and and and what that and those
those tensions are just going to keep on
coming and make it very difficult for
the Tory party to pull together
I also think on as Well's Point there's
there's a fascinating we have people at
Westminster has not resolved what they
want the whips office to be you know it
used to be that the whips officer kind
of like regimental sergeant majors got
everyone in line marched them through
with some pretty tough language and
pretty tough words you know that has
gone out of fashion MPS are now more
independent-minded but equally the whips
office is not a kind of fully
functioning HR department and so I think
this question of how do you find a way
to balance the need for
um for for proper HR at Westminster
something I mean no one can deny as
needed and the fact that government need
to be able to get their business through
the House of Commons and if they can't
get the business through the house
comments they can't function you know
how to do that I think is something that
hasn't been worked out and as well you
mentioned when you're writing for coffee
house this week at pmqs that sort of
soon out resembled almost like a midterm
leader rather than a new one um do you
get the sense that these problems are
going to persist for him
I do and I I think some of the the
people who are
um exacerbating those problems not just
those who you know are accused of
um inappropriate behavior like Gavin
Williamson if you look at you know
former party chair Jake Berry who
um has been part of this uh campaign
against Gavin Williamson but also has
been uh very difficult for which you see
now Consuela bravaman I I think there
were a lot of
ex-ministers EX Liz trust supporters
whatever who still see themselves as
being part of a different faction to
Rishi sunak and who are you know not
happy and so it was always going to be
the case that all this talk of unity in
the days and hours after which you see
that became prime minister it was you
know nonsense and wasn't gonna last uh
but as we know and as James has written
about everything is you know at warp
speed now in conservative politics it
really is almost as though you know when
you're fast forwarding something on your
TV and you can choose between eight
times as fast or 32 times as fast we're
just speeding through everything at 32
times at the moment and so Rishi sunak
has has gone straight into a sort of
midterm situation but that's partly
because of where the conservative party
is you know that they are still
knackered they've still been in
government for a long time
um they're still struggling to work out
what they stand for
um and you know who should be a part of
them and who should shouldn't be a part
of their electoral Coalition and
I don't think that the feeling that
they're heading into a period of
opposition that that might not be a bad
thing has really gone away despite the
change of prime minister
I think Matt Hancock is actually a
fascinating example here I don't I'm not
going to ask you to eat anything um John
because look I mean my uncle tells a
bigger more important story which is you
know here he is someone who back where
she's doing that for the leadership
fiscal conservative
um yeah when he didn't get a job in
government his view was well look I've
served in the cabinet in two different
roles I've been at the top for a long
time I'm going to go off and do my own
thing even if that lands me in trouble
with the whips now he's chosen to go off
and you know eat kangaroo Parts not long
on a reality TV show I'm not suggesting
that there's going to be whole numbers
of slew of former ministers appearing on
reality TV shows across the country but
I think what it does tell you is you
know how hard it is to control people
who feel that they've got to the Top
Been There Done That and aren't going to
come back and I think that you know one
of the natures of the fact that as
Israel said that the stories have been
in power for so long is that there are a
lot of people who've got to the top sat
around the cabinet table or you know and
are now back mentions again and and
controlling them is always very very
difficult brilliant thank you James and
thank you Isabel
I mean Matthew's rights in this week's
magazine about the history of nuclear
weapons the people who made them he
explains thought they could even
possibly end War altogether to discuss
Owen joins me now
so start us off I think so actually an
interesting point to start off with I
think is that when you're talking about
the evolution of Warfare It's almost
like a common view that these inventors
of quite efficient weapons that somehow
if they come up with the Ultimate Weapon
it will kind of reduce War
um yeah can you tell us a bit about that
yeah well that's really the point of my
piece is really to chart the history of
how mutually assured destruction which
was the idea that nuclear war was
Unthinkable because it was unwinnable
and was mutually assured suicide for all
the parties I was actually been eroded
and that's what the danger of Putin's
nuclear threats are is that he's
actually threatening to end that taboo
and by using so-called tactical news and
as I write in the piece actually
tactical nukes include really quite tiny
weapons but the point is like it's not
the Tactical it's the nuclear part that
we need to be worried about so the
question really is is there really any
such thing as a tactical Nuclear device
because for instance today the bomb that
destroyed Hiroshima in 1945 wood is 20
kilotons it's equivalent to 20 000 tons
of TNT that would actually be considered
sort of a medium-sized tactical Nuclear
device today so uh and the biggest
nuclear devices ever detonated are two
and a half thousand times bigger than
Hiroshima in 1961 that was the biggest
ever so the question is is not the scale
of the bomb it's whether the tactical
Nuclear use you know can actually ever
enter the world's in a military sort of
vocabulary again and obviously we fear
we we fear Putin Putin is used not
because of the destruction that any
tactical nuke will wreak in the Ukraine
but what it will unleash and the kind of
scale of escalation that we can expect
afterwards you mentioned your piece that
this has sort of been tested before in
the Soviet Union I think it was about
zhukov can you tell us a bit about that
yeah well in 1954 uh with the greatest
the greatest General the Savior General
of World War II really was a great
advocate of the battlefield use of
nuclear weapons he thought it was just a
bigger bomb it was just a big apartment
he actually tested it on on whole
division of soldiers in 1954 he just
marched them into The Hot Zone
um and uh so I thought that it was it
was not his own soldiers and saw that it
was actually not immediately fatal and
that was good enough for the Soviet
Commander so actually
um the the the Soviets were actually
very keen on it but at a certain point
both superpowers realized that actually
this not only mutually assured
destruction was dangerous and
destabilizing but Battlefield use of
nukes was also as well so strangely
enough actually the the the taboo has
remained even as bigger and smaller
nukes have been developed the taboo has
remained since 1945 against their
Battlefield use you feel that's eroding
now
that's uh well clearly that's a huge
concern and as we've seen in the water
the the the uh from The Washington Post
has reported there's actually been quite
a lot of uh back Channel confidential
contacts between the um the United
States
um and uh Nikolai Patricia for the
second most powerful man in Russia the
chairman of the security Council
specifically about the use of nuclear
weapons and clearly
um I mean as I write in my book
overreach was out this week uh one of
the biggest Untold Stories of the
Ukrainian war is that China and the us
actually have some very strong Common
Ground over the use of tactical nuclear
weapons and they're both disapproved in
the strongest possible terms and it's
actually one of the biggest frustrating
factors luckily for us and the world uh
on Putin's nuclear uses that Beijing
very strongly disapproves of that and
has actually made it very clear to Putin
that that is a deal breaker for their
relationship the use of Battlefield
nuclear weapons slightly heartening at
least
um so if nuclear weapons are used by
Russia what kind of things would we
expect would it be a sort of Hiroshima
style attacking a civilian City do you
think or would it be more like to be
used sort of in the battlefield against
particular positions or is that just
Unthinkable stage well I
um I I don't think that there's actually
um been any serious consideration of how
it would actually play out in a military
scenario because there is no such
scenario where the Tactical use of
nuclear weapons would actually help in a
battlefield condition
and that's really the whole point of
this of of the story as that the
tactical use of nuclear weapons has to
be as suicidal for the aggressor as the
Strategic use of nuclear weapons
otherwise the world turns into a far
more dangerous place
and I mean it's a bit worrying though do
you think
what do you think the worst reaction
will be if any companies are used I mean
you mentioned that you know in the past
the Cold War you know we've all been
sort of Saved slightly by a mutually
sure destruction in the sense that one
use of nuclear weapons would you know
receive a huge humongous response do you
think that's the case today though or do
you think Russia could almost get away
with it no I think that's that that's a
very clear red line and that's something
that the all the West nuclear Powers
um that have made it very clear that the
West's response to a nuclear attack by
Russia will not itself be nuclear but it
will be conventional and will be
devastating if those are the words that
have been used by the US Administration
and the Really sort of rammed home so uh
and and that's the really crucial thing
is that Putin needs to realize that it's
in the the end of his regime but on the
other hand
um there is a scenario whereby if the
alternative is
in rolling the dice and hoping that the
West's response is survivable and the
collapse of his regime after a
battlefield drought or the collapse of
his troops on the ground and you know
revolutionary situation inside Russia
you know there's a whole sort of cascade
of extremely dangerous situations that
could come out emerge from a battlefield
catastrophe in a major collapse for the
Russian military and in that in that
scenario for Putin to consideration is
in a dewy risk a conventional response
you know versus an inevitable and
complete collapse of our regime that's
the moment where he's cornered and
dangerous but do you get the sense of it
that there are kind of any internal
restraints on Putin so people inside the
regime who might be able to say well if
we're using nuclear weapons we're gonna
we're gonna stop you essentially I think
um that's what the Chinese are hoping
and the Chinese have actually been
working very hard on their military to
military contacts because they've been
doing joint uh military exercises with
uh the the Russians for for you know a
couple of decades now actually
and uh the Chinese have actually been
making an effort to sound out
top level commanders with whom they have
been working who how they have a working
military relationship
to ensure that the deployment of
Battlefield nuke doesn't go ahead but
the danger is not a planned
and considered use it's as a desperate
final
experience by a desperate regime I think
that's the only scenario where the use
of a tactical nuke could be
could be realistic and that's in fact
why the United States has actually been
frankly very cautious about arming
Ukraine and so restrained by arming
Ukraine so in that sense like in that
sort of magical power of nukes does
pervade this entire War because if
Russia did not have nuclear weapons and
there was not even a tiny chance that
they might use them then the war on the
ground would be completely different
then it would be like you know they've
been white off the Army will be wiped
off the face it would be like you know
Kuwait 91 again I mean there will be no
question but the nukes are what makes
the West treat Russia with kid gloves
and actually make the chaotic fall of
Putin actually very dangerous scenario
far more dangerous than it would have
been obviously without a nuclear element
because he could use them all because
someone oh
take over well both of those yeah
and this week as well we've seen that
Russian troops have sort of pulled back
from Kirsten do you think we're going to
get to the sort of point where if
Ukraine carries on advancing the kind of
risk of nuclear threat goes up as well
as almost if the ukrainians get close to
the Russian border itself well the risk
is if there is a major route of the
Russian forces and the Russians get
kicked out of all the territory that
they have taken and there's a serious
pressure on Crimea and the rebel
republics of the donbass in that
scenario then there is an increased use
of a desperate regime doing desperate
things but we have to remember we're
incredibly far away from that and for
the ukrainians find themselves in a very
difficult position because they have
been their war of effort is 100
dependent on Western support right now
this year the west by the end of this
year the West will have spent 27 billion
euros just paying Ukrainian government
salaries wow
um so that's and and Military salaries
so the the ukrainians are desperate
they're extremely Brave and they're much
better Army they're much better
organized they're much better motivated
this is all these are all things that we
know but actually on the ground the the
the
Russians have lost
depending on how you count it but
they've lost up to 20 percent of the
territory which they have initially took
from the Ukraine but that's 20 of the 20
of Ukraine that they have so in fact
they have actually nonetheless kept a
gigantic and very strategically
significant economically significant
chunk of the country so so the question
comes much much much further down the
line after a series of Ukrainian
hypothetical military victories that
kick the Russians not only out of heads
on but as a militarpal and crucially
mariopal you know that I've seen of
those sort of extraordinaries and tragic
and insane destructive power of the of
the of the Russian military yeah but you
know that we're a very long way from
that I mean Ukraine needs much more
troops and it needs much more Firepower
in order to do that and frankly I didn't
think that that's going to happen I was
going to say it must be a source of uh
possible hope for the Russians in a
sense that the sort of the interest in
Ukraine will Wane in the west and what
does that do if they can hold on to
their positions then they're still in in
quite a good good I suppose well that's
precisely what CIA director Bill Burns
said in August he said that you create
the the Russians are calculating that
the uh that the West is going to lose
interest in Ukraine and um
I think he's uh I think Putin is I think
Burns is right that's exactly what the
Russians are trying to are calculating
but I think uh Putin is wrong in one
respect and write another he's I think
he's he's wrong that the moral support
will Wane the power of public opinion
and the weight of public opinion uh to
back the ukrainians morally I think is
not going to break but the question is
practically and you what you see in lots
and lots of surveys and particularly
those the european-wide survey even at
the end of the summer asking respondents
in 10 European countries or I should say
nine European countries in Britain
thanks to you guys
about whether the populations favored
peace or Justice and actually the
results are as you would expect like in
the Poland and the Baltic republics were
very much in favor of Justice in other
words like bringing bringing Putin to
Justice ending the war with a just
situation but actually Germany for
France especially Italy are for peace
what does that mean peace inevitably
means land for peace it's a compromise
on the ground and that is unfortunately
something that's not really politically
survivable not only for zelensky but for
any Ukrainian Administration so they
find themselves in a major bind they've
committed themselves to never talking
peace with Vladimir Putin it's actually
a law that was passed by zielinski uh
earlier this month uh late last month
and he's um and at the same time
committing not only to
Antebellum you know pre-invasion
withdrawal of Russian troops but
zelenski is insisting that he was that
he on the return of Crimea and and
donbassy Ukraine neither of those things
are remotely achievable or even
desirable frankly I mean is Ukraine
really going to be in the business of
fighting a war to compel crimeans to be
part of a country the Ukraine but they
don't want to be part of I mean that
that doesn't really make any sense at
all but the problem is that he's saying
that because his people 93 of his people
of the Ukrainian people believe
themselves to be uh capable of winning
of achieving total military victory
and so far
they are indeed winning but
unfortunately they're winning rather
slowly in a certain point I think the
inevitable result is going to be
stalemate and it's at that point that
we're going to have to we're going to
see that friction between the Europeans
pushing for you know land for peace
peace at a price
and the ukrainians who are vowing to
fight to the end and that tension is
going to surface but very painfully and
whatever happens mark my words whatever
the end of this war the ukrainians will
be betrayed will feel betrayed they will
claim to have been betrayed you know
that they will have that their land has
been sacrificed to appease Putin and I
thought but unfortunately I don't in
realistic military terms actually see
any other weighted that this any serious
other outcome for this war than an
eventual territorial loss for Ukraine
because Putin has nukes and Ukraine does
not
there's a bizarre campaign in Scotland
to try and cancel the philosopher David
Hume in the magazine this week Stuart
waiton says the people behind it are
rewriting history to try and recast
Scotland as patriarchal and oppressive
Stuart joins me now Stuart thank you for
joining us on spectator TV now you write
in the magazine this week that Scotland
is undergoing an exercise in rewriting
its history
um can you tell us a bit about that
please
but it's hard to know where to start but
um at the minute where we are is that
there has been a kind of review into
edinburgh's past including its uh past
relationship to slavery
um and what's what kind of triggered the
debate within Academia at least around
this issue is the uh a plaque that has
been put on Henry dundas's statue
so Henry Dundas sort of late 18th early
19th century very significant
um politician and the plaque has been
basically says he was responsible for
delaying the abolition of slavery and is
responsible for the sort of the the
lives deaths and misery of half a
million black people and this plaque has
been the front of the group who have
developed this black is a guy called uh
Sir Jeff Palmer there was a professor
either seemed a professor of history or
philosophy but he's a professor of
Brewing
um but he is black and he's Scotland's
first black professor
and I'm assuming that at least in part
that was the reason that he was given
this job if you like to look back over
edinburgh's
dodgy racist past but like with most
things it seems to be done very much
through the lens of today rather than
with any historical accuracy
um so so I'll just stick with that story
at the minute before we jump on to other
stories but uh in relation to that story
what what essentially happened is that
the key historians who were already a
bit confused about why this group that
had been set up in Edinburgh didn't have
any historians on it because you'd think
if you're looking at history you might
have some historians at least no as they
say no professional histories
um and they looked at what was being
said on the plaque and said well
actually if you look at the recognized
historical work and knowledge on this
subject what is being said about Henry
done this here is absolutely nonsense
right and I've got this I'll have some
quarters not going to do it if you want
them from there's a New Zealand
Professor so Tom Devine who's probably
the most celebrated academic in Scotland
in the last 50 60 years uh and the
citizen Andrews professor of History all
just said this was absolute nonsense and
Jeff Palmer in his wisdom uh decided to
call them all racists or part of a
racist gang a bit like the KKK perhaps
bearing in mind that Tom Devine is a bit
left-wing yeah he's a bit of a Celtic
man as far as I know
um and there's nothing racist about Tom
Devine Tom Devine is outraged by this
um and is equally outraged as far as I
can tell from conversations with the
fact that the Edinburgh University
principal refused to defend him uh Tom
divides an Emeritus professor at
Edinburgh
um and as I say he's a sir he has won uh
a half a dozen awards for his history
he's actually written a book on slavery
in 2015.
um highlighting this so that's one
dimension of it
um so that's that's one dimension of the
story but there's also a group has
argued that that black should be removed
so that's ongoing and there's only been
any response from Edinburgh to this sort
of charge that these allegations against
Dundas are kind of unfair and
unhistorical
um limited as far as I can tell and um
Jeff Palmer defends himself by saying
well uh even Tom Devine said that Dundas
was responsible in the past and and so
on and I think there's some truth to
that Tom Devine had raised this but it
was like
seven years looked over the work and
said actually it's much more complicated
than that
they've done desk and
it can be so essentially the the the
body of historical knowledge as is
um entirely refutes this uh this
accusation and this plaque so
essentially it's it's you're you're
rewriting history that's what it's being
seen as you know this is a direct
uh assault on history and falsifying
history in fact
um and part of the process that's
happening at the minute is Jeff Palmer
has argued that slavery should be taught
in schools the same as maths and English
um as it happens I spoke to a teacher
and he says well it's already becoming
like this that slavery's just becoming a
kind of you know it's that everyone
teaches this as he described it it's
this Scotland Slave past it's we've
become the new Nazis so it's uh it is a
highly moralistic and modern day
political Drive
to essentially develop what I would call
as a form of indoctrination
um rather than education which just has
a slight sideline
um I I've just set up an organization
called the Scottish Union for Education
which subtitles uh education not
indoctrination so we're going to
actually try and create a movement in
Scotland to challenge the various forms
of indoctrination that have taken place
in schools which is why I went to see
Jeff Palmer at Dundee University
and can you tell us a bit about when you
were there you sort of heard his
comments about David Hume is that right
yes yes yeah so this is um so I went
along because I knew
thought I knew
was going to be which and it was even
more
um jaw-dropping than that which is Jeff
Palmer gave a talk
I should come back to doing the
university by the way in terms of why he
was invited because that's another
spin-off but anyway Jeff Palmer was
invited to talk
uh as part of a cleansing episode for
Dundee University which has labeled
itself a racist institution uh bizarrely
um based on research but I can mention
that if you're interested
um so so I I went along uh uh and Jeff
gave a chat about himself and his past
and so on and then he started to make
these comments about
all of which I would challenge so he
says modern day racism is based on
slavery
I think is a rather cross and
historically not very useful
understanding of modern day racism
he also said that the reason that so
Scottish people still have this feeling
that Negroes as is he talking about the
David human quality which I'll get to he
says that Negroes are inferior to whites
that's a Scottish people still feel that
apparently I've lived in Scotland for 30
years I must admit I've never come
across Scottish people thinking that
Negros are inferior to white people and
I'm to be honest with you I don't
believe Jeff Palmer actually believes
that himself if I'm absolutely honest uh
but he went on and explained that a key
problem and a key reason that the
slavery was celebrated and even and
chattel slavery and released Africa was
developed at the late 18th century was
because David Hume in one footnote in
one of his Works in 1748 and said that
he thought niggles were inferior to
white people as it happens as far as
dividium was opposed to slavery but
anyway he was he made this what we now
see is a racist comment in a footnote
that nobody had ever heard of as far as
I can tell unless you've um I'd never
heard this about David you certainly
didn't seem to reflect anything about
his work his body of work the
Enlightenment and the progressive and
positive uh influence that Humes had on
uh philosophy and the history of Western
civilization
and he was a man of his time as well it
seems quite it's almost unfair to judge
him from the from the morals of the day
after your your Watchers and readers
appreciate that but yes talking about
someone in 1740 through the uh the
prison of 2022 uh and being shocked and
outraged is uh is infantile
um to say the least so yes and he went
on to say so the Hume apparently was an
ant [ __ ] uh had a great influence on
intellectual influence to support
slavery
um the uh that footnote has continued to
be significant in terms of
um
racist sentiment in Scotland
um which is one of the reasons we should
get rid of the David Hume Tower or the
name of David Hume Tower of Edinburgh
University which we can come back to
um and yeah and he even said uh which is
I think my Joe I had to scoop it off the
floor at this point when he said when he
saw George Floyd dying he thought of
David Hume and again I'm not sure I
believe that's true uh and for some
reason
possibly influenced by modern thinkers
who he's come to know over the last few
years
this was an essentially an assault on
the Enlightenment and an attempt
Enlightenment individuals and an attempt
to try and suggest that these
individuals are centrally responsible
for slavery and for modern racism
um and I think you could talk to almost
any historian or uh philosopher of any
worth and if you made that suggestion
they would uh you know
be shocked yeah I mean it's some
remarkable statements I mean what what
do you think the purpose of this is to
it I mean to sort of underline the
enlightenment is it it's about
institutions just caving in or is it
about individuals do you think why is
why are people going along with this
well it's a long process I think it's a
long process through the 20th century
where liberalism was found it difficult
to find a kind of moral basis for itself
into legitimize itself and it's been
yeah the history of the 20th century is
the one that has been a history that's a
lot of problems and difficulties in
terms of living up to the ideals of the
Enlightenment the idea that we live in a
rational world and so on
um and that I think that we now have
principles principles in a lot of
universities and institutions that don't
really know what they're for and have
lost to a fair extent the enlightenment
Legacy
um on top of that you have this new kind
of therapeutic Dimension to things so
the question of race see I don't even
think the issue of racism Now is really
about racism is such I think it's more
anti-racism
seems almost like a religion today
there's it doesn't follow a logic
necessarily
um so for example you can you can say
you're not interested in Black Culture
and that makes you a racist and you can
say you're very interested in Black
Culture and that can also mean that
you're culturally appropriating and a
racist in almost any anything is done
through this new prism of uh the idea of
whiteness and the original sin of white
privilege so you've got all these new
types of
um
uh uh the kind of
more corrosive and reactionary forms of
anti-racism and you've got institutions
who struggle to actually know what
they're for struggle to understand that
a university should be about actually
knowledge and Enlightenment Russian Arty
uh and so on
brilliant and thank you Stuart for
joining us
and finally in the books pages of this
week's magazine spectator contributors
have put forward their books of the Year
let's talk about them I'm joined by a
literary editor Sam Leith
um so you've got the books of the year
in the the books pages this week and
last um some fantastic contributions
we've got everyone from am Wilson uh
William dalrympel Andrew Roberts Susan
Hill
um were there any particular
recommendations that people had of books
that they liked this year that you that
you particularly agreed with
well I don't I mean it's always
interesting to see what
the range and Randomness or quite
Randomness but the there's a range for
the people we ask the fact we get I
don't know 20 or 30 people a year to do
it
um is you get a mixture of
you know Trends emerging like we you
know we've seen a lot of love for
instance for volume three of Simon
heifer's chips Channel
um letters well without Diaries sorry
which you know it's a sort of big and I
think very spectatory piece of kind of
political and social history
um and you know you sort of see
you see the the books that you know kind
of everyone's talked about the Prize
winners the you know big names we've got
a new novel out and then sometimes it's
kind of interesting when when you
what I like about it is when something
that I hadn't thought of at all comes up
and what what are the pledge those books
the year features as well is that you
always get a few people who don't read
anything from this Century at all
um let alone this year so I think it was
Graham Rob this year he said you know
I've I've only been really 18th century
stuff and we go well why the hell not
you know it'll be a surprise it's got a
Christmas stocking or a brand tub of
stuff
um it also if they serves quite a good
purpose
for me as a literary editor which is
that every year there are two or three
books that for one reason or another
because I ran out of time I couldn't
find the right critic they got squeezed
out the publicists you know for some
reason didn't let me know they were
coming out
um or assuming I knew anyway there are
what you know in the technical job of
the trade we call cock-ups that occur
when very good and distinguished books
just don't get a review and I'm always
kind of slightly mortified and one one
this year that this happened to
um was Jonathan friedland's book about
this escape from Auschwitz which
everybody says is wonderful he's a great
writer it's absolutely up our street we
should have done it and I only really
clocked it about three weeks after it
come out so I'm delighted that at least
two people have given it a good word
um so that's a good sort of backstop for
us um I'm still very much hoping someone
comes up with Max Hastings book about
the Cuban Missile Crisis because our
reviewer for that if you're listening to
Max sorry I would did commissioner
review our reviewer slightly fell under
a bus and wasn't able to do it in the
end and so that's the sort of thing that
happens anyway We've Ended on a quite
pessimistic event there just raking you
over the coals
um how about that but yeah it's great
it's great to see what they do and also
sometimes I won't mention names it's
interesting when there's a book that's
very very much hyped and nobody picks it
yeah I mean you know pilot I always does
that thing of
actually authentically extraordinarily
excellent the strangest child and they
did a spoof books of the year which
literally everybody said you know the
new Alan Holiness doesn't have list
um and some years that really happens
and this year you know with some writers
it didn't well that's good I mean I
think um Roger Lewis had probably the
harshest take of the year is that I
think he said that you know literature
has reached a dead end
um and so there's nothing modern even
Hillary mantel is going to collect dust
on the shelves kind of thing um do you
agree with that yeah
you might remember this is a very
successful Christmas series of Christmas
books called seasonal suicide notes um
and being a sort of you know Jeremiah of
you know that's kind of his his shtick
I'd be I'd be disappointed
um I should say that the other thing
that books of the Year allows reveals to
do sometimes I think it's let off a
little bit of steam
um so you are like you know I write when
I write to them I say look please choose
the you know greatest books this year or
if you like one or two there's a
unaccountably overrated because there's
nothing like a little bit of birth
um
and
I also see it as a place in which
because you know there's going to be a
little log rolling I mean it's that sort
of feature I mean so explain explain log
rolling first rolling log rolling Mutual
back scratching it's the business of
people
um giving a nice
your little plug to a book by their mate
or you know someone who shares a
publisher or an agent or their wife or
whatever it is
um and I kind of ordinarily got very
strict rules
um I'm pretty kind of cromwellian about
not letting people review their friends
or for that matter their enemies um I
think they might be exceptions to that
but generally
um I don't think it's a service to the
readers whereas books here I think it's
kind of baked in that it's a slightly
corrupt Enterprise that people can plug
their friends
um I mean one year there were two two
very distinguished contributors who I
both of whom I love and admire
enormously and they happen to be
practically Neighbors in Cambridge and
they both plugged each other's books and
my brilliantly fiendish colleague Claire
who does the layouts just without any
traffic I'll just put the two books of
the years right next to each other
and one of them is a very distinguished
person was so extremely cross note
saying and you Stitch me up this is
awesome I said oh it's all Claire's
fault
all good food all good food and I always
quite like as well if you've got like um
contributors you know who disagree with
the same book I mean I think you had a
bit of tension over in the qn this year
isn't that right
yes I will yeah Marcus Marcus um Berkman
because sort of it's kind of peculiar
thing here I mean I like iron I know a
lot of other people thought Ian's new
book was terrific
um but Marcus sort of stepped out from
behind him
pillar and kind of baseball batted it um
and then went to his back catalog you
know bayonetting the wounded
quite like that as a as a thing you know
a bit of disagreement is is one of the
things that adds uh it's Pepper with
pages and I you know I'm not answerable
for what my critics write very often I
disagree strongly with what they write
particularly when they write very unkind
things about books by my friends
um but you know so it goes and yeah I
mean that's the essence of literary
criticism and literary taste is that
disagreement is very much available and
you can be as Vice as you like
and and finally Sam would probably
remiss if we didn't ask you know one of
your favorite book's been of the year at
any particular that you'd recommend to
viewers uh as they're trying to fill up
Christmas stockings quite soon
well I'm glad that you asked asked me
that but I'm more glad that you warned
me in advance that you're going to ask
me when everyone says oh your books
editor if you read any good books lately
I'm always like oh no can't think of a
single one but the one book this year
that I have been running around pressing
on people
um with great success is Andrea Wolf's
book magnificent Rebels which
it's about the first Romantics and I I
obviously thought in like a jejune way
when I first heard of it oh I'll be good
at Coleridge and Wordsworth and so forth
and it's not about the German Romantics
um her part of this great original
intellectual movement and it's all the
sort of fixture and schliegel and Hegel
and shelling and
um you know extraordinary kind of
collection of really important German
intellectual figures
um so you get this great trench of
intellectual history that's really
important and does feed into our own
Romanticism but at the same time they
all lived in this tiny little village
for a while in Vienna and basically they
were all sleeping with each other's
wives writing each other vile Anonymous
reviews feuding stealing each other's
work arguing so it's essentially kind of
EastEnders with German idealism and it's
so beautifully written and so
fascinating and interesting and such
kind of lively story that I really very
very strongly recommend that because you
know I learned it also stops me having
to read fiction and myself
um so I'm very grateful for the for the
primer it contains brilliant that sounds
fascinating thank you very much Sam
that's it for this week once again don't
forget to subscribe to The Spectators
YouTube channel just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the Bell icon so you never miss an
episode
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]
thank you